wow huge menu about 100 options there
yes help me out um you could do five
calamari it's very good is it it's one
of my favorites let's go for the fried
calamari over season salad okay and then
I'd be stupid not to have the bomb the
bomb Burger the bomb Burger does it look
like that ah yeah
do you know what I'm a big lover of mac
and cheese do you have any mac and
cheese yes yeah lovely that'll be all
right you got it thank you thank you
water you want to throw in a macaroni
and cheese
150.
water up Ash
that's mine I think that was very fast
oh my God
probably pre-made
[Music]
yeah it's a mouth look good that's gross
that doesn't even taste like it's been
cooked here we don't make the mac and
cheese no it tastes like that is that a
big hit no it's what the kids eat it
ready uh yeah that's Dreadful poor kids
damn you think a menu with classic
American you've at least made your mac
and cheese right yeah it's not good like
really sorry I don't really know what to
say because I'm not the one making the
food I'm just serving it what do you say
said it was gross
I just hope he doesn't run to the
bathroom
oh if I call Mario overseas herself
Let's uh let's taste
not good
it's kind of nice really soft and sort
of chewy different
oh
uh I don't think I'm really should be
touching food yeah don't worry it won't
bite
yeah it's uh
it's fresh but it's frozen because it
tastes Frozen yeah
yeah stressful
anyway definitely not for me um I'll
finish thank you okay you're welcome
are we making out Ash you said they were
a girl soft and chewy we're soft and
chewy the caramine
it's not crispy
I wasn't a great feeling when he was
sending back all the food you know it's
what we do every day we think we do a
pretty good job he wants the bomb next
everyone loves the bomb
that's one of our house Specialties we
was definitely gonna enjoy that one
all right the bomb Burger
wow
[Music]
where's the burger
ah there she is there is the book
we probably won't like that either
how is everything but does anyone season
food season it yeah salt and pepper uh
we don't add anything to it when wow wow
the meat's really chewy
chewy as hell we ask the chef to taste
that okay damn
thank you you're welcome
um you said the burger is really chewy
he said try it
[Music]
chewy that's weird
it says on the menu the way mum used to
make that has to be the biggest insult
to every mother in America
embarrassing because those are our most
popular additions I was really shocked
the kitchen here right can I meet the
chefs or introduce me to the team this
is Kevin my son how are you doing how
are you likewise so you're the head chef
yes and this is your son right on a
scale of one to ten rate the food in the
restaurant
between six and seven six and seven I
would have said six
half it and take two away and you you're
on my mark
it just looks disgusting
cream it's always ice cream yeah
it just looks like lobster is dead
before they cooked it they're from the
largest from the tank you want to take a
lot okay
you did
no I think they're just sleeping it must
be dead we keep a good eye on this you
keep a good eye on them surely not
they spot dead a dead lobster no he's
gone
what I'm concerned about is everything
else in there they've been feeding off
that Lobster don't become full of
bacteria
but that is extremely unacceptable
dangerous people can get extremely sick
with that I'll get rid of this right now
okay please
all right love you bye
[Music]
it don't smell that Lobster's fresh even
though it died it's good this is my
birthday hey Michael
pretty good good I'm doing fine thank
you I know you saw Lobster in there that
passed away well I try to we try to
check that every day well it's just
slightly concern to see the deadlops is
in there I try to freeze them right away
and then I make the best from there okay
you must be busy all right thank you
enjoy thank you
okay I want to say everywhere now the
chicken and garlic sauce
uh what is all that in there the green
olive oil garlic we've got a little bowl
for just drinks what I have it's like
they're swimming thank you
oh dear it's like a [__] Exxon Valdez
there too much olive oil for it
you think there's too much olive oil in
there
it's like a half set waiting to happen I
hope it's a hospital nearby
the chicken tastes absolutely Dreadful I
just want you to taste the chicken let's
taste that
literally it's dry you sound like a
position now okay I'm not [__] around
that's gross do me a favor can you ask
your brother to taste that yeah
I want you to try this
what's the next dish
so in the fire
papaya
what did Michael say he's trying it
right now we're gonna find out
what do you have to say
have faith on me baby this ain't a
normal guy it's a bread huh they're pain
in the neck
he thought it was [__] good
wow if he thought that was [__] good
then I'm screwed if you're screwed
imagine how I am
and this is the uh I am marinara The
Lobster in this boy did it come from the
tank
[__]
okay
you know or would you be so kind to
taste it for me yeah
badly badly seasoned yeah
it doesn't overcook this is ridiculous
that this pan even came out add respect
for your granddad that is a joke
give me five minutes we'll have a chat
together yeah please thank you
Chef you like to have some dessert it's
very kind but I've lost my appetite
thank you beautiful color
peace
Jesus it's like somebody's dropped
sliced onions into boiling dish water
Dreadful how's the French onion yeah
after a bad start unfortunately
it's like someone's pissed in My Soup
[Music]
well that's not good we'll take this
away
[Music]
that was Dreadful all right um guys the
French onion he said it's like pissed
flavor he said it was not good
[Music]
I told you that onion soup wasn't right
we know I know
how are you going to get your kids
please
I don't know I'll find out the kitchen
staff will do what they want to do and
do as little as possible which should
grab the ball by the horns and be in
command all right shepherd's pie here we
go thank you Gabrielle he makes a good
shepherd's pie
all right Chef thank you shepherd's pie
wow it's a very bizarre looking
shepherd's pie someone put grave on top
of my crispy Mash yes that is a shocker
like someone's snot all over my mesh and
that gravy is made from beef
beef stock on a shepherd's pie and
shepherd's pie is made out of this one
this one actually beef so there's a
cottage pie not a shepherd's pie because
Shepherd stands for the
she
EP I'll be back to check on you
cold congealed gravy just like glue
so how are we doing
gross and it's not hot either
that's partly the reason why they're not
coming back it's just watery
there was two strokes right away and I
was fairly confident that he would like
one of them at least you're right fine
it's good
[Music]
that's his face
batting zero yeah the big
Swift see he's just not what he's doing
but just [__] up everything here
all right Chef this is our broad
Fisherman's Platter flounder scallops
and shrimp thank you
[Music]
[__] it oh my god oh boy that's gross no
good Chef soft Bland rubbery I didn't
realize it could be this bad thank you
okay
which can be blind and I'm not Kenya
he's [__] piano yeah all you have to
do is do what I told you yeah well I'm
not you can go in there dad
oh no this was not good this is the
worst of the work till the end oh you're
here 16 years so you think your food is
decent to hear otherwise it's kind of
shocking I don't know if I can make it
through this
if I did the very lazy cook ain't
nothing even fry the eggplant anymore my
mother and father end up crying
ridiculous
made yesterday it was actually made
three weeks ago
yep three weeks ago
yep that's disgusting you go grocery
shopping three weeks in advance before
you're gonna eat the stuff no
all right give me a pen I need to keep
score
it's one down one eggplant not good
that should be fine
what's next
and with these Maids yesterday
I'll make sure I get a deed on that
good
foreign
does that they are not homemade
I definitely feel dumb you know here I
am telling people all the pastas are
handmade because that's what Frank told
me I feel betrayed and My Own Boss
that's it's not right
that's nasty the lobster ravioli is
store-bought so it's not fresh no hold
on a minute hold on we're backtracking
now fresh pasta every day all the passes
in me yeah all handmade I thought they
were made fresh
[Music]
that's gross you can never see the Frank
Frank why ain't the pastors hear me why
don't you come in earlier and make
pastas so I hope that you can get
through to him because he is a good Chef
what is he a passionate chef
[Music]
no
jeez okay um thank you Andrew
[Music]
you say you like that you didn't like it
you hated the lobster every year
I really want to please the guy I know
he's not complain I mean come on at
least like tell me if the sauce is good
that's all I asked she doesn't like this
then like what the [__] I'm busting
again
just gotta like something
just serve the name God let the Rosemary
crust and then the Barillo red wine
sauce Bon Appetito thank you
what kind of crust is that Rosemary
Rosemary Pat
it's burnt and bittered when garlic
Burns it goes bitter guy can't even
taste lamb
I [__] them bad by some of the dishes
that came out
wow and again passion gone Anthony take
me to the kitchen please let me get a
word with Frank I'm definitely think
what squealed
okay let's start I sat down I got told
the past is fresh I got excited it's
homemade and it's coming from the heart
all of a sudden you've got this ravioli
Lobster that's store-bought
it was horrible but how was the sauce
cooking some [__] about the sauce The
Filling is the magic whether it's a
ravioli tortellini it's the filling you
get excited about
big problem well that was a disaster
spongy bitter undercooked and then I got
told you it was cooked three weeks ago
embarrassing I mean it's really
embarrassing you can't make fresh food
and freeze it and charge money to
running a [__] business if you're
going to be bothered to cook fresh Foods
what do you want me to do
wave my magic wand and turn this place
around come on
that's what I do I don't know how to do
any better that's a lie you could do
much better or do you want to do better